お、
行け行け。
俺のことフォローしてる?
してる。しる。
じゃあこれラブあげるよ。
え、ラブやった。
うわあ、水色だ。やった。欲しく
時代はラブよ。買いに行くわ。あ、
お金がない。
そうだ。屋根ちゃんのお年玉貯金から使っちゃおうと。むほ。
おい、俺のために貯金してくれてるって言ってたらじゃんか。私が産んだから。お前の彼は俺のものを。ラブ。
あのデベおばさん絶対許さねえ。
みんな助けてくれ。
ラブブラブ。
俺のトラップにかかったな。ラブ行こうと。あれ?先生。あ、息子がいつもせになってます。は。うん。ま続くのよ、この道。
お母さん、そこは異変に気づいて戻らない限り無限ループする
番出口だ。異変を探すのね。はい。先生はくとハゲかけてるし。
歳で独身だっけ?公務員でそれってだいぶ異変じゃない?
誰が変だ?
異変だから戻ろっと。俺は正常のようにする。
今がチャンスだ。タイルマンは触れたら即死。
誰だお前?ああ、大
つ次は赤い水だ。これで流してやる。
お、ちょうどいいじゃん。
おい、どうやったら出れるか言え。絶対ありがとう。ここか。
[笑い]
おい。よし。
タクシーるじゃん。
やけ。あとは頼んだ。
くそ。次は聞いただ。
あ、乗ります。よいしょ。じゃあラブブショップまでお願いします。はい。え、ちょっとこっちじゃないわよ。ねえ、タクシー戻って。ここじゃない。ニュータン目指して。さよなら。ハイウェイ。やもん。
着きました。あ、僕のお金持ったから無茶を作ったよ。ああ、何これ?楽しい。
行っててって。あら、広いじゃない。
僕の家金持ちだから。鬼をたくさん取ったよ。
さあやっておしまい。
わ、鬼さんたちだよ。
ああ、極楽、ご極楽。
おい、何くついでんだ。じ、地上に戻せ。
お、オ、何をもう。
え、ラブ、
ラブ売ってま。
え、ラブ買いに行くわ。
よし、よくやった。こんじり。
[音楽]
ラブどこよ、ここ。あ、ラブブだ。ラブ。
やっと追い詰めたぞ。
あ、
ただお母さんは最強だ。お年玉を取り返すために画面の前のみんなの力を貸してくれ。
何人でもかかってきなさい。
てなわけで1月10
日はここ横浜開記念会にみんな集まってくれ。
バンカラジオ初のライブイベントお年玉泥ラボをキーコを倒せチケットは先着順です。
QRコみんな読み取ってね。
イ
え、ライブ歌歌えるの?じゃあ私モンスターマ歌います。
ハッピーハッピーハッピー。
勝手に歌いな。
お前ら勝手にチ取るな。
じゃあチ期販売もしてみんなで写真撮ろう。
2026年1月10
日はファンカラジオと一緒に最高の盛りして
J